hinter ihnen liegen heimat und
hausarrest vor ihnen die sonne und
sangria jeden tag kommen ein dritter
flughafen linienmaschinen an viele aus
frankreich für die passagiere ist es
eine mischung aus urlaub und flucht
wir wollen unter freundinnen ein
wochenende hier verbringen um kuwait in
frankreich hinter uns zu lassen und das
zu genießen
in madrid und bars und restaurants
geöffnet wir wollen uns erholen und das
leben wiederfinden so wie vorher zu
hause ist alles kompliziert alles zu
regeln die einkäufe zu schaffen
es gibt keine restaurants keine bars man
kann sich nicht einfach mal mit freunden
treffen
ganz ehrlich das wurde einfach zu lang
und zu heftig in der abwägung zwischen
vernunft und versuchung gewinnt oft die
sonne
lilo und paul sind aus der normandie
hergekommen sie besuchen freunde die mit
dem erasmus programm in madrid sind 120
euro für das ticket kurzentschlossen
griffen sie zu die auflagen sind nicht
eben streng
ich mache zwei tests einen vor abreise
in frankreich und einen hier vor der
rückreise
denn man muss am flughafen einen
negativen ich habe mir gesagt es ist
zufall ob man das virus bekommt oder
nicht
man kann es hier so gut bekommen wie in
frankreich aber wenn scheint hier ich
glaube es gibt weniger völlig entspannt
stadtführungen fast als wäre nichts
tatsächlich sind es besucher aus dem
ausland die hier das leben in gang
halten die franzosen fliehen vor den
einschränkungen in frankreich und sind
fasziniert dass wir erst spät
ausgangssperre haben dass die bar
geöffnet sind und dass alles so lebendig
ist
jede region in spanien entscheidet wie
streng sie sein will mit ihrem chor ohne
einschränkungen oder eben nicht und die
region madrid will so gar nicht streng
sein
restaurants und bars sind geöffnet
draußen und drinnen mit begrenzten
plätze
die polizei schreitet bei dem bunten
treiben nicht ein auch wenn keine masken
getragen werden so viele leute in den
straßen und in den restaurants offene
restaurants das ist erstaunlich
erst um 23 uhr beginnt die
ausgangssperre bis dahin sollen vor
allem die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
korona krise möglichst begrenzt werden
es bringt nichts alles dicht zu machen
man muss mit dem virus leben lernen
vorsichtig ja aber eben leben
wir können nicht eingesperrt bleiben das
bringt nichts und hat desaströse folgen
für die wirtschaft und aus
psychologischer sicht auch lieben und
pohl und ihre freunde finden wir in
einem restaurant wieder drinnen und ohne
maske sie wissen warum das zuhause
anders ist
wir gehen ein risiko ein
aber es gibt abstand zwischen den
tischen mehr als einen meter voneinander
das empfehlen sie und wir passen auf
wenn wir mal zur toilette gehen oder zur
bahre dann tragen wir maske aber wenn es
ein problem gibt dann war das unser
fehler dass wissen wir wohl voll und
lilo machen es damit wie madrid selbst
sie gehen bewusst ein risiko ein
der unterschied madrid macht das auch
aus der not heraus spanien gehört zu den
ländern in der eurozone die
vergleichsweise wenig öffentliche gelder
investiert haben um die folgen der
epidemie zu bekämpfen
mangels masse muss man abwägen die
pandemie bekämpfen hat priorität aber
wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen dass die
wirtschaftliche und soziale situation
die auf uns zukommt sehr kompliziert ist
die folgen sieht man hier ein
ärztezentrum im osten von madrid viele
der menschen die hier anstehen haben
symptome und wollen einen test machen
infektionszahlen in spanien gehen ein
wenig zurück seit dem höhepunkt der
dritten welle aber madrid weist höhere
werte auf als der rest des landes
mediziner und politisch verantwortliche
bewerten das vorgehen denn auch
unterschiedlich als gesundheitspersonal
halten wir die laxen restriktionen für
schlecht weil wir sehen dass wir es so
nie schaffen werden die fälle zu
kontrollieren
im moment denken die zeit
das bedeutet dass wir uns auf leichtere
einschränkungen einlassen können als die
die wir derzeit haben und die es uns
erlauben werden die wirtschaftstätigkeit
so weit wie möglich zu erhöhen
nur wenige krankenkassen vertreten auf
die britische währung so dass die
kapazität spaniens nicht sehr großen den
tatsächlichen prozentsatz der mutationen
noch zu
die mutterfirma
so ist spaniens die lockerheit gleich
mehrfach riskant die feiernden und
touristen halten wie dieses bildmaterial
der polizei zeigt oft auch die wenigen
auflagen nicht ein die es noch gibt die
wahlpartys sind verboten
am vergangenen wochenende zählte die
polizei hunderte davon
und dann ist da auch die gefahr dass
sich mit den virus mutationen die
fallzahlen recht schnell wieder erhöhen
lille und polen nutzen derweil die
möglichkeiten die madrid ihnen bietet
ohne überlaufen zu sein
das tut gut wir wollten diese werke
schon lange mal sehen hier im reina
sofia museum gerne kam so zu sehen
das ist und so ist dieser besuch am ende
beides eine flucht vor dem virus und
eine erinnerung dass spanien schon
schlimmeres gesehen und überstanden hat
[Musik]